hello and this is Matthew from simply
learn and today we're looking at how we
can use Shep to improve the way that you
administer hard work within your DevOps
environment there's gonna be six things
that we're gonna step through the first
is really looking at what is the world
that many of you already work in today
well how do you administer your networks
and your systems today then we're gonna
look at how chef's can be the tool that
really helps improve the efficiencies of
creating a consistent operations
environment we're going to look at the
tools and the components and the
architecture that takes to construct
chef and then finally we're going to
take a use case of one of the many
companies that are using chef today to
improve the efficiency of their
operations environment so let's take a
step back at what life was like before
chef this may well be the life that
you're experiencing right now so as a
system administrator typically the way
that you work is that you are
responsible for the uptime of all of the
systems within your network and you may
have many many systems that you are
responsible for now if one system goes
down that's not a problem because as a
system administrator you can get
notifications and you can jump right on
to the problem and solve it when things
start getting really difficult however
is when you have multiple systems and
you are not able as a single person to
get to all those systems and so them as
quickly as possible
the problem that you start having is
that your environments are not in sync
if only this could all be automated well
this is where chef comes to the rescue
for you so let me take some time and
introduce you to the concepts behind
chef and why it's a tool that you would
probably want to be using in your
environment so what actually is chef so
chef is a way in which you can use code
to fix your physical hardware
environment and so what does that look
like well the way that we write out
scripts in chef is and you can actually
code your entire vironment
so you don't have to actually be
managing
your environment on a hardware why
Hardware basis but actually use scripts
called recipes that will actually manage
the environment for you so chef will
actually ensure that every system is
automatically sent to the right states
that meet the requirements you have
defined in your code so you don't have
any issues where hardware and starts to
fail because it references the code to
reset the state within that environment
and that makes you a happy system
administrator so let's go through the
mechanics of how this actually works
with chef so chef is ultimately an
automation tool that converts
infrastructure to code and you'll often
hear the term infrastructure as code or
IAC and this really starts as a output
of the work that chef has done because
you take the policies that you as an
organization have created and you
convert that into a scripted language
that can then be implemented
automatically this enables chef to be
able to manage multiple systems very
very easily and considering how broad
and deep our systems become it's very
easy to see how this can help you as a
system administrator the code is then
tested continuously and deployed by a
chef so that you're able to guarantee
that your standards and appropriate
state for your hardware and operating
environment are always maintained so
let's step through the different
components that are available in chef so
the first one is actually creating the
actual recipes for chef so you actually
welcome these on a workstation and
you'll write out your code which is
referred to as a recipe and that recipe
will be written using a language called
Ruby good thing for you is that there
are lots of examples of Ruby's recipes
that have been created by the
open-source community a lot of examples
knife is the command tool that you use
that communicates between the recipes
and the server so your recipe is the
instruction and knife is the tool that
makes that instruction work and sets the
appropriate state on
server environment when you create more
than one recipe you start creating a
collection those collections are
referred to as cookbooks and you may
take an environment such as a large snap
bug where you have multiple nodes
potentially Congress or servers that
have to all have a consistent and equal
state environment and you would put that
cookbook and use that cookbook to ensure
with chef that the state of each of
those foods is consistent and then Ojai
fetches the current state of your nodes
and then the chef client configures the
nodes as defined within your cookbook so
let's step through the architecture and
working environment of chef so for an
administrator a systems administrator
you only have to allow work from your
workstation and from that workstation
you can then configure all the nodes of
your environment you can use different
recipes that you create and those
recipes can be compiled into a cookbook
that can be then applied to unknown the
thing that's all value is as you change
the environment as you move and mature
as an organization and your nodes need
to mature consistently and quickly with
your organization all you have to do is
roll out a different recipe to your
nodes and then the nodes will use the
tools within chef to make the updates so
you can create a second recipe or even a
third recipe to be deployed out to your
server environment knife is going to be
the tool that does the hard work of
doing the updates on the server with the
server you have over your collection of
recipes in a single cookbook however
understanding the state of the
individual nodes is important to ensure
that the information is broadcast from
the server with the instructions on how
to set up the network within those nodes
in this instance we use Ojai and Ojai
will fetch the state of the nodes and
send that back to the server and get the
information from the cookbook using the
chef client in your chef node network
there is the potential at time
that may be one of your node fails if
there are two failed nodes then a
request is sent back to the server and
information on the latest node structure
that is identified and defined in the
cookbook will be sent to the failed
nodes if that fails to reset the nodes
then the workstation is notified and you
as the administrator will receive a
notification to manually reset those
nodes it should be noted that this is a
very rare occasion within the chef
network setup so let's step through a
use case and this instance we're going
to look at Napoleon and how they used
chef so a poem is a bank and it's the
largest bank in Israel and they have a
mixture of Linux and Windows servers
that they have to maintain and as you
can imagine this requires a lot of
constant configuration and work and this
has led to issues in the past so the
challenge that the team podium face was
cravings and hardening software that ran
the major tasks and was repeatable on
those servers
that it didn't matter who the people
were forming the jobs that there was
consistency in the work that was being
done and addressed the problem that the
server's including the hardware and the
server's was not consistent throughout
the organization
Chev addresses those specific problems
and became the go-to product for hope
Oleum they were able to write the
recipes and the cookbook that could be
deployed out to the network effectively
and it didn't matter what the system was
the recipes reflected the standards that
the system administration team put
together and they were able to ensure
and test each script and use standard
testing tools for those scripts it
didn't matter what kind of environment
that appalling had if certain ports need
to be closed or if a firewall needs to
be installed or modified or if custom
strong passwords had to be created all
of this could be done using the recipes
that chef offers and once those recipes
had been finalized they could be
packaged into a common cookbook that
could then be deployed to the entire
network ensuring a consistency and
results for the company and also it
didn't matter whether the cookbooks were
being deployed to Linux or Windows
machine because the scripts were being
put together in the recipes and were
written in Ruby you could actually go
through an update and modify those
scripts depending on the environment so
if you needed to make a modification for
Linux you can make those modifications
so they were consistent across all the
Linux servers or all the windows servers
and this really drove in the ability to
harden and secure the environment in the
entire network within a matter of
minutes using chef versus the days and
weeks that it previously took so we take
a before and after scenario using a chef
before chef tasks were repeated multiple
times and it was just hard to keep track
of all the people doing the work and the
reality is because so many people were
touching all the different systems
specific standards that the banks had
established were simply not being met
after chef all of the tasks could be
scripted using Ruby and using the recipe
and cookbook model that chef has created
the chef tool was able to deploy how to
the entire network specific cookbooks
that provided a consistent experience
and consistent set up an operation
environment for all the hardware the end
result is that the system administration
team could guarantee that the standards
of the bank were being met consistently
so just two takeaways that we have here
of Chef so life before chef is
complicated if one server goes down you
can probably get it back up and running
but if you are working in modern system
administration environment you have many
systems and if multiple systems start
going down or having failure points it
is difficult to identify where those
failure points are and how to solve them
chef resolves this issue and it does so
by turning
the environment that you're managing
with hardware and software into code and
once you have it written as code you're
able to then test that code
chef itself is made up of a number of
key components as a system administrator
you work on your desktop at your
workstation and you create recipes those
recipes are then bundled together into a
cookbook and that cookbook communicates
with the server the main chef server and
the node of servers within your
environment and knife is the tool that
does that communication oh hi and the
chef client on the various nodes service
will communicate back to the chef server
what the standards and the environment
are so that they can provide a two-way
communication to validate that the
system has been set up and is being
maintained to the same standards as
defined by the individual recipes as an
architect and working in this chef
environment it makes it much easier for
you to be able to control the entire
system administration instead of having
many people having to work on all the
servers you can now have one person
controlling hundreds of servers
simultaneously and a polum have been
able to prove conclusively that chef is
a tool that can help improve the
consistent experience of working with
hardware so I hope you enjoyed our quick
class today
this is Matthew with simply learn and
signing up if you have any additional
questions reach out to us in the
comments below and we'll get back to you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here